e aí pessoal que existe no canal tudo
bom vocês meu nome é o início muniz eo
dele é rafael coelho
depois de tanto vocês pedirem a goiás no
entanto vocês pedirem vai ter outra quem
não sabe no piauí assim uma série onde
este fã dos costumes as expressões e das
palavras que fala aqui no piauí é
sergipe assim ela tem como finalidade é
explicar para vocês de um jeito que a
gente fala aqui no piauí não é errado e
sim construir aquilo que a gente está
sempre procurando ensinar vocês falar
pra falar da então a gente está sempre
procurando ensinar vocês há como falar
as palavras aqui para quando você vê o
piauiense ele falar com você você
entender que a primeira gíria é aqui
lugares não tropeces trupica a trupe cão
menino
a própria expressão seguinte o jovem que
aqui no piauí um certeza falou isso aqui
ó mãe bêbado mel porque o piauiense é
canhoto natureza naquele trabalho que se
esforçado e aí tem que falar o mãe bota
túnel que se não tem graça casa não tem
raça casa porque há muito e esse caminho
é dar um zoom ou é amargo demais meu
filho a de seus colegas falava não fica
desse movimento lavar meu filho
alexandre ramos falava eu fui fazer essa
dignidade pela manhã ele é bruta de mais
adoro jogar bonito tem pregado a gente
tem menino também foi acatada resfriada
e fica tudo aquilo que acha que tem
pregado por rancor nem desgraçado tu
acha que tem praia na rua nestor roupa e
pra quem entrega da rocha tarde para
montar hotel e altônia e o que significa
e eu topo disse que no piauí no piauí
essa expressão não pode significar
qualquer coisa por ele
e eu tô alejado ou por acaso não posso
fazer isso pode significar várias coisas
mães ela vai ficar na pauta o chuchu
metrópole placa mow baixo ao bayern
toffoli os doces cachaças hoje é claro o
amor e chegou poderei então é isso aí
pessoal muito obrigado por você quer
assistir esse vídeo que foi um vídeo na
série no piauí é assim que você não está
inscrito neste canal quer saber quando
terminou com quem escrevesse esse vídeo
ajudou de alguma pois vocês você gostou
clique aqui gostei você está pensando ah
faltou digital a autogirar ana e bento a
falta de ciel que calma que ainda vai
ter mais vídeos e vocês vão ver as
outras filhas e ler me segue no twitter
que está aqui segue o jovem está a
granja viana instagram assim a gente o
facebook faz o país não faz o que quiser
muito obrigado te falou